[Music]
113 questions about evolution with John
Perry evolutionary question number four
kadai 'no sores ever be cloned like in
the movie Jurassic Park last week I
published a new animation on the stated
clearly Channel about the discovery of
soft tissue inside dinosaur bones dr.
Mary Schweitzer was the first to
discover soft tissue she found
microscopic remnants of blood vessels
inside of a t-rex leg bone and since her
discovery many other groups have found
similar things in different dinosaur
specimens and one of the big questions
that people have been asking probably
the number one question that I've been
getting is does this mean that we can
finally clone a dinosaur can we make a
real-life Jurassic Park
I hate to be the bearer of bad news but
the answer sadly is no and there are
three main reasons for that the first
main reason is that we have not been
able to pull any DNA sequences from
these dinosaur bones it does look like
there are individual DNA nucleotides for
those that don't know a chain of DNA is
made up of a whole series of DNA
nucleotides and we can read those
nucleotides to understand the genetic
information of an organism but the DNA
inside these dinosaur fossils is
completely deteriorated it's broken up
into individual pieces trying to
actually read a dinosaur's DNA from
their fragments that we found in these
fossils would be like trying to read the
works of Shakespeare from a bowl of
alphabet soup we cannot read it because
it's too broken down we're actually not
even sure if the DNA that we're finding
in these fossils even comes from the
original dinosaur even if we're looking
at a mummy for example that's that died
a couple thousand years ago when we try
to sequence a mummy's DNA mostly what we
get is bacterial DNA actually less than
1% of the DNA that we find in mummies
actually belongs to that mummy most of
it is bacterial or fungal DNA the oldest
fossil that's been able to give us DNA
sequences actual DNA sequences is a
horse fossil that was dated back to
seven hundred thousand years old
so that's much much more recent than any
dinosaur fossil that we have and even
that it was the DNA was broken up into
fragments and we had to sequence the DNA
of multiple cells and then overlap those
fragments to try and figure out what the
entire sequence was it was a lot of work
and we can't do that with Dinosaurs
because the fragments that are left are
not long enough now there are several
laboratories that actually thought that
they had found sequences of dinosaur DNA
in their samples but in all of the cases
so far it's been contamination one of
them was contamination from a turkey
sandwich it happens
the second big reason that we can not
clone a dinosaur is that we do not have
access to dinosaur eggs we do have lots
of fossilized dinosaur eggs but this
doesn't
Thrones those are not going to work most
of you are probably aware of Dolly she
was the first sheep that was ever cloned
and the way that we cloned dolly is that
we took an egg cell we pulled out the
nucleus of that egg cell and then we
took an adult sheep cell we pulled the
nucleus out of that adult sheep cell and
inserted it into the egg that egg then
acted as if it were fertilized by a
sperm and began to grow it was implanted
into the uterus of a sheep and Dolly was
born this process requires not only the
DNA from an adult animal what we would
be trying to get from these these
dinosaurs soft tissues but it also
requires an egg cell and where the heck
are you going to get a dinosaur egg cell
if the dinosaurs are all extinct I
actually can't remember if it was in the
movie or if it was in the book in
Jurassic Park they solved this problem
by using ostrich eggs and emu eggs that
actually would not work when we do
cloning experiments and we use an egg
from one species and the nucleus from
another species the thing almost always
dies the only way that it won't die is
if you're using an extremely closely
related species the reason for this is
that there are certain proteins and
enzymes RNA chains in an egg cell that
have to match the DNA of that egg cell
as well you need the right goop inside
your egg in order to make a clone the
third reason that you cannot clone a
dinosaur is that in order to clone an
animal you need not only the DNA
sequence but you need intact chromosomes
a chromosome is a stretch of DNA along
with packaging proteins and those
proteins not only package the DNA inside
the nucleus of the cell they also help
regulate gene expression those packaging
proteins help decide what genes get used
at what time so if you don't have those
proteins along with the DNA you can't
you cannot make a clone now some of you
have probably heard that we are trying
to clone a mammoth and we actually think
that this might be possible but we're
not actually cloning it in the same way
that we cloned Dolly the sheep in order
to clone a mammoth what scientists are
trying to do is they're trying to
sequence the genomes of mammoth fossils
and mammoth fossils are young
that we can sequence their genomes
enough of their DNA is intact we're
looking at those at those genomes and
we're comparing that to Indian elephants
and what we're trying to do is we're
trying to genetically engineer Indian
elephants to express traits that are
similar to those found in mammoth DNA
that means that they're going to have
more fat underneath their skin they're
going to have shaggy fur they're going
to have longer tusks and smaller ears
and those traits will allow them to live
in colder climates now
as fascinating as I think it would be to
meet a woolly mammoth in real life or a
reverse-engineered woolly mammoth in
real life I care about the well-being of
elephants and in order to make these
we're going to have to impregnate a
whole bunch of Indian elephants with
genetically modified fetuses pregnancy
lasts almost two years an elephant it's
18 months 18 to 20 months for an Indian
elephant that's a long time to be
carrying a baby that's probably going to
be deformed these are highly emotional
animals they're sentient creatures like
you and I I don't feel like it's it's
worth the suffering that it has the
potential to cause but people are trying
to people want to do it I will be very
curious to see the outcome of those
projects there's also another project by
Jack Horner who was trying to
reverse-engineer a chicken to make it
look like a dinosaur he wants to make a
chicken with a long tail with a toothed
snout and with scales instead of
feathers so anyway to sum things up can
we ever clone a dinosaur like they did
in Jurassic Park
sadly the answer is no at least not with
today's technology next question